Russian air defenses shot down 45 drones targeting a Russian military base in Syria,...
...which functions as a main hub for Russian authorities in Syria.
In Germany, Greek and German governments made an agreement...
...on taking back refugees who request asylum...
...and appear at the border between Germany and Austria.
In Spain, the country pays homage to victims of last year's attacks...
...that killed 16 people on the streets of Barcelona and Cambrils...
...on the first anniversary of the tragedy.
In Peru, families and relatives of missing people...
...from the conflicts between Peru and Maoist terrorists in the 1980s and 1990s...
...now can meet them with the help of forensic scientists.
Finally from France, a volunteer created a smartphone application...
...explaining biblical scenes on 15 stained glass windows...
...in a royal gothic chapel called "Sainte Chapelle" in Paris.